We all know how to brush our teeth, right?
How old are we when we learn to brush our teeth?
Three, four, maybe five years old.
Well, I've got some news for you.
How we brush our teeth contributes massively
to the fact that nine out of 10 adults,
over 30, have active gum disease.
Wouldn't it be great if there was a technique
for brushing our teeth that was scientifically proven
to reduce the bacteria responsible for gum disease?
Well, there is.
Today, we're going to cover the vast brushing technique.
It's the only brushing technique that is scientifically proven
to disrupt this organizer and remove the bad bugs
that cause gum disease from our mouths.
So before we get into the technique,
let's cover a few points about Dr. Bass.
Dr. C.C. Bass is the guy who created the vast brushing technique.
And there's a couple of interesting notes about Dr. Bass.
I want to bring up that I think will help the understanding here.
First of all, Dr. Bass was the youngest person
to ever be assigned a deemed position of a medical school.
He was very into microbiology.
He had a lab and a biology lab in a microscope.
And he was actually the first person
to carry a microscope west of the Mississippi River.
So that kind of gives you a time frame
of when Dr. Bass was a practicing physician.
So he was a fairly young physician.
He was diagnosed by his dentist with advanced gum disease
called parodontal disease.
And the suggested course of treatment from his dentist
was to have all his teeth pulled.
Of course, isn't that the answer?
Well, being the type of person that he was, Dr. Bass
wasn't satisfied with that.
So he went back to his lab
and he was determined to find a technique
to stop this parodontal disease.
So what he did is he took samples out of his mouth
and he put it under his microscope
and he easily identified a number of the bacteria
that we now recognize as what are called pariodontic
pathogenic bacteria or gum disease causing bacteria.
We call them bad bugs for short, okay?
Yeah, he identified a lot of these bad bugs.
And so what he did was a trial and error experimentation
where he would take a sample out of his mouth
and look it under his scope
and then he would brush his teeth
and he'd take a sample from the same spot
and look under the scope again
and count the bacteria until he found a technique
that significantly lowered the number of bacteria
after he brushed his teeth.
That's slightly scientifically proven.
He figured it out, okay?
So here's a couple of his findings that he found.
First of all, these bad bugs hang out along the gum line.
So it's very important to brush along the gum line
and the second finding that he found very quickly
in his experimentation is that two brushes
weren't doing the job.
They all had too many bristles in them
and they just kind of mashed around on the teeth.
So what he did is he took a toothbrush
and he kept pulling bristles out
and removing more and more bristles
until he got a technique that would wiggle down
into the gum line to disrupt
and disorganize these bad bugs along the gum line
which is where they live and thrive
and cause companies and create all the problems that they do.
So what we have now from Dr. Bass are two things.
First of all, is the vast toothbrush.
This is a toothbrush that Dr. Bass designed
based on his research in his own mouth
to bring it down to a point, bring the bristle numbers
down to a point that will actually wiggle down
under the gum line instead of just mash around
on the teeth themselves.
So a couple of interesting features about the vast toothbrush,
it has very, very few or much fewer bristles
than what we would call a common toothbrush,
or a regular toothbrush.
And also the bristles have rounded tips.
This is very important actually
because a lot of toothbrushes out there
have rough cut bristles and then actually etch
and damage the teeth, etch the enamel on the teeth
and irritate the gums.
Actually one of the most common signs
of gum disease is receiving gums
and receiving gums is definitely caused
by the bad bugs that cause gum disease
but it's also caused from brushing the teeth
too darn hard with these rough cut bristle toothbrushes.
So the vast toothbrushes are really cool design.
It's got much fewer bristles to facilitate the use
with the vast brushing technique,
as well as having rounded tips on each bristle tip
that have rounded, so it's much gentler on the gums.
The second thing that we have from Dr. Bass
is the brushing technique itself.
All right, I'll get into the specifics
of the brushing technique in just a moment here.
And the third thing we have from Dr. Bass
is his life as an example.
You remember his dentist diagnosed him
with advanced gum disease, their periodontal disease
and the course of treatment was to pull all his teeth, right?
Well, history says that Dr. Bass died an old man
with all his teeth still on his mouth.
So that speaks very loudly to me.
So let's get into the technique.
Couple of points about it, first of all,
the toothbrush needs to be angled toward the gum line.
Now the gum line is where the teeth come up
out of the gums, right?
I don't mean to be silly here, but it's where the teeth
come up out of the gums.
So you're going right along the gum line there
with the technique.
And the technique is specific in that you're doing
micro movements.
You're not brushing over the teeth.
You're just vibrating the toothbrush in place.
So it's a very different brushing technique,
which is why the cute kids in the beginning of this video
can't do it.
They don't have the fine motor control
and the muscle control to be able to do the vast
brushing technique, which is why we need to learn it as adults.
And then while we're in position,
we want to count to five in each position.
So we like to do this vast brushing technique
with a gentle, safe antimicrobial or antibacterial solution.
Since you're getting the bristles of the brush
down into an under the gum line a little bit,
why not put a safe antimicrobial?
It's going to kill the bad bugs naturally as well.
OK, we use the oral on this brushing blend for that,
because the brushing blend blend of organic botanicals
does a fabulous job of safely and efficiently and effectively
killing the bad bugs that cause gum disease
without putting toxins in our mouth.
So let's go over the technique.
Instantly gum disease really hangs out
along the gum line in the molders in particular,
so really pay a lot of attention back
into the molder area while you're using the technique.
So that's the vast brushing technique,
angling it towards the gum line, micro movements,
wiggling it, vibrating it down into and along the gum line.
Now, you can try this with a kind of a commercial toothbrush.
Generally, what I found is it has much too many bristles
in the toothbrush head to be able to wiggle down
into the gum line along the gum line like we're
looking at this technique is really looking to do.
Excellent technique, it really helps reduce and eliminate
the bad bugs in our mouth.
It causes gum disease, helps you to control the bugs in your mouth,
and will lower the incentive gum disease.
All of the many questions we're here to help you
take control of your oral health.